una receta para galletas de avena
contiene 2 tazas de harina por cada 3
tazas de avena cuánta harina se necesita
para elaborar una gran cantidad de
galletas que requieren 9 casas de avena
veamos que nos dan nos dan 2 tazas de
harina nos dan entonces dos tazas
de harina dos tazas de harina por cada
tres tazas de avena por cada tres tazas
de avena dos tazas de harina por cada
tres tazas
de avena es la receta y lo que nos
preguntan es cuánta harina se necesita
para elaborar una gran cantidad de
galletas que requieren nueve tazas de
avena así es que ahora tenemos una
situación en la cual se requieren nueve
tazas de avena déjame ponerlo aquí nueve
tazas de avena nueve tazas de avena y te
quiero mostrar distintas maneras de
hacer esto para que elijas la que más se
te acomode a una manera de razonar esto
es bueno sabemos que por cada tres tazas
de avena usamos dos tazas de harina
ahora que vamos a usar nueve tazas de
avena cuántas tazas de harina requerimos
eso es lo que nos están pidiendo si
vamos de tres tazas de avena a nueve
tazas de arena cuánta avena más estamos
usando bueno estamos usando tres veces
la cantidad original de avena estamos
multiplicando por tres al multiplicar
por tres las tres tazas de avena
obtenemos nueve tazas de avena si
queremos usar la harina en la misma
proporción tenemos que usar tres veces
la cantidad original de harina entonces
multiplicamos por 3
estas dos tazas de harina por lo cual
requerimos usar 3 por 26 tazas 6 tazas
de olvídate de este signo 6 tazas de
harina es la respuesta es la cantidad de
harina que se necesita para elaborar una
gran cantidad de galletas que requieren
9 tazas de avena otra manera de
encontrar la solución es estableciendo
la proporción si sabemos que por cada
dos tazas por cada 2 tazas de harina se
requieren 3 tazas se requieren 3 tazas
de avena entonces cuál es la cantidad de
tazas de harina es una incógnita vamos a
ponerlo con una variable x 1
pongámoslo como un signo interrogación
dentro de un cuadrito para que así te
quede más claro de qué se trata todo
este proceso entonces cuál es esa
cantidad de tazas de harina que se
requieren para combinarse con 9 tazas de
avena yo prefiero el primer método que
hicimos pues
simple sentido común sí triplicamos la
cantidad de arena tenemos que triplicar
la cantidad de harina para mantener la
proporción de la receta por el otro
método establecimos esta ecuación que
hay que resolver
usando álgebra algunos le llaman
multiplicación cruzada pero esa
multiplicación cruzada está basada en el
álgebra y te lo voy a mostrar en la
multiplicación cruzada se hace lo que se
llama una multiplicación en diagonal en
este caso estaríamos multiplicando 2 por
9 2 por 9 2 por 9 que es igual al
producto de este signo interrogación por
3 el producto de este signo
interrogación lo que sea que represente
en este caso las tasas de harina por 3 2
por 9 es igual a interrogación por 3 2
por 9 18 que es igual a esa incógnita a
ese signo de interrogación en un
cuadrito por 3 así es que el número de
tazas de harina que se requieren x 3 es
igual a 18 mentalmente podemos calcular
que el número que se multiplica por 3
para dar 18 es
y no podemos vivir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 3 para obtener 6 llegamos
entonces a que el signo interrogación en
un cuadrito es igual a 6 tazas de harina
la misma respuesta que obtuvimos a
través del sentido común ahora tú
podrías decir esa multiplicación cruzada
que hicimos no tiene ningún sentido
intuitivo que es lo que hace válido
igualar esos productos cruzados porque
es válido multiplicar el denominador de
un lado por el numerador del otro lado y
eso que sea igual al numerador de un
lado por el denominador del otro lado
eso sale directamente del álgebra y para
ver eso voy a sustituir esta incógnita
por x tenemos 2 sobre 3 es igual y en
vez de este signo de interrogación voy a
escribir
x sobre 9 algebraica mente estamos
estableciendo que esta cantidad de aquí
es igual a esta otra cantidad de aquí un
principio básico del álgebra es que si
hacemos algo del lado izquierdo de una
ecuación para mantener la igualdad
tenemos que hacer lo mismo del lado
derecho en este caso lo que queremos
hacer es simplificar esto para dejar del
lado derecho tan solo la equis y que
necesitamos hacer para que esté x sobre
9 se transforme en x al estar la x
dividida entre 9
multiplicamos por 9 los 9 se van a
cancelar y habremos despejado la x como
dijimos también necesitamos multiplicar
por nueve el lado izquierdo si estos dos
términos serán iguales antes de
multiplicarse por nueve para mantener la
igualdad hay que multiplicar por nueve a
ambos lados de la ecuación del lado
derecho estos nueve se cancelan y nos
queda tan solo la equis mientras que del
lado izquierdo tenemos nueve por dos
tercios esto es como nueve sobre uno por
dos tercios esto es igual a dieciocho
tercios y por supuesto ya sabemos que
dieciocho tercios es igual a seis todos
estos métodos son válidos este
desarrollo algebraico que hice aquí lo
hice para que te dieras cuenta que es
válida la multiplicación cruzada que
usamos sin embargo para un problema tan
simple como este tan solo necesitas
sentido común si estás aumentando las
tasas de avena por un factor de 3
entonces aumenta las tasas de harina por
un factor de 3